on this cyber monday did you even know
it was cyber monday it is the national
retail federation expects e-commerce
to grow 20 to 30 percent over last year
americans could ship
3 billion packages between thanksgiving
and christmas
now that's up 800 million from 2019.
that's a lot of packages
shippers were already at peak capacity
due to this pandemic
chris van cleave is in united airlines
cargo facility
that's at dulles airport that's outside
of washington d.c so chris here's a
question united is also going to be
helping with the vaccine distribution
so will everything get there on time
they got packages they got vaccine they
got lots to do
well good morning gail the short answer
is no millions of packages potentially
a day will be late so you need to ship
early now for
airlines cargo has been a real rare
bright spot they're going to pick up
some of this surplus and that
includes the vaccine united has already
started flying the vaccine in fact and
they can store temperature sensitive
things in rooms like the one behind us
here
the vaccine of course is going to be
given top priority
holidays or not alyssa patnato is
starting early and doing almost
all of her holiday shopping online but
worries about her gifts
arriving on time i feel like
shipping this year is going to be a task
you know
i think people are going to get backed
up shippers like fedex have been at peak
christmas shopping levels
since march the pandemic has packed
three years of anticipated e-commerce
growth
into just eight months when you think
about this holiday season it really is
a peak on top of a peak ship matrix
estimates
shippers can handle around 79 million
packages a day between thanksgiving and
christmas
but americans are likely to send 87
million
daily that means seven to eight million
packages
each day could be delayed people need to
be prepared
for their packages to be late some of
them yes and they also
can help by ordering in advance and not
procrastinating
till the final week of christmas and
that's before shippers are also asked to
deliver the coronavirus vaccine as soon
as mid-december
fedex will use its fleet of planes for
the vaccine while its ground operations
handle the bulk of the gifts
the vaccine distribution is the most
important thing that we are preparing to
do
over the next several months united
airlines has added 8
000 cargo only flights so far this year
that's in addition to the cargo carried
on passenger flights coming
and going to more than 100 countries
daily
everything from fresh fish to the u.s
mail and now
the pfizer coronavirus vaccine this is
essentially a giant refrigerator and
it's where united would put something
that needs to be kept cool
until it gets picked up by another
shipper this
all pharmaceuticals here waiting for
delivery
united's kate harbin we recognize that
this is going to be the biggest
distribution challenge that the airlines
and in
fact the supply chain in general has
faced in our lifetimes
there's concern that there's not
capacity enough
to deliver everything on time it's a
concern and that's why we're preparing
for all possible outcomes and this is
something not just united is preparing
for
but the entire industry
now shippers say that today and tomorrow
are going to be among the busiest days
between now and christmas
every monday leading up to christmas
also very busy
so whether you're the post office fedex
ups
all the shippers agree on one thing if
you're going to send your gifts and you
want to ensure they're there by
christmas
they need to be mailed by december 18.
you have 19 days and counting
anthony okay i'm writing that down chris
thank you very much 19 days no to family
it's okay if my gifts are late
vaccine gets out first that's right
everything to get that vaccine out
thanks chris